our call-in marathon continues now
we're highlighting key events from each
year since our first regularly scheduled
national collins show began
25 years ago
right special orders sometimes they're
special sometimes they're not so special
can i ask you a question when you hear
that b1 noise flying overhead
what do you think to yourself when it
rattles your windows a little bit
because rapid city is ellsworth air
force base right thank god for that too
that's right just think to yourself the
sound of freedom
the government is thinking i would call
two trillion dollar deficit thinking
these guys okay fifty percent pay raise
for themselves
and to me this is so outrageous it is
just so
absolutely ridiculous you're right as a
matter of fact
it would be an example for the rest of
the country for these top officials
starting with president george bush to
say
times are tough we've created this huge
debt this huge deficit
program cutbacks around the slate we're
going to take
take a pay cut just imagine the respect
and support
they would get from the people the
homeless issue and the hungry issue is a
very
vital security to our nation and i think
when it comes
time to helping the hungry around the
nation
and when we think about the the effort
that both
both both even president reagan and
gorbachev
have planned needless to say on some of
their meetings even though
they have talked about disarmament but
they've also talked about helping the
hungry
we're finding a new phenomenon we're
finding the working
homeless in other words somebody with a
job unable to afford a home
and not just not as part of us not just
part of our country it's not part of the
american dream it's not part of anything
all black youth are dying at a
proportional rate
that this time around to vietnam you
have not mentioned it
at all no one has mentioned it all young
black men are dying at a rate of 1 out
of 22.
i mean no one is even talking about it
that concerns me very very very much
saying that i am a black man i know that
uh
crime is the leading cause of death
among
african-american males between 18 and 24
not heart disease not cancer and so what
we've been discussing here
is uh how are we going to deal with the
issue of drugs
how do we bring that to the forefront
people in this country
don't understand when the house
gives something to the to the president
he does not have to go by what the house
wants he can cut and he can cut the
money
they are blaming the democrats for all
the cutting and that is the problem
uh it seems to me that uh in the fiscal
squeeze we're in now
and inevitably we're going to have
squeezes on some parts of the budget if
we're going to get our fiscal house in
order which i think has to be a top
priority
that's john kane floor director who's
doing all the
shaking around qs to get started here
and
hour 10 of our 90-hour call-in 25-hour
call-in
marathon the topic 1989 in the u.s
role in the world the guest christopher
hitchens vanity fair columnist
among other things it was 1989 that the
berlin wall came down
december 1989 christopher hitchens
november november pardon me um
great time for the west wasn't it yes it
was um well no it was
a great time of the east actually i mean
because
that that moment in berlin uh
was created by a movement of people from
hungary through romania all hoping that
they could
escape the grip of the warsaw pact
comic-con regimes and
begin to travel open themselves to the
west of it and at a certain point the
east german government said well
i remember the i remember the
announcement very well because they said
we may have to open the borders and i
remember thinking open their borders
does that mean the wall
is coming down didn't hit me right away
but a few hours later people were
dancing on top
of it but a few hours after that they
were taking hammers to it
i still have a chunk of the wall on my
mantelpiece
at home but politically wasn't it a
great time for the west was it the uh
did
we looked great in the the world's eyes
at that point
and is it do we still have that same
feeling well for a lot of for a lot of
people in the west it was a feeling of
vindication that
it had been worthwhile fighting the cold
war
that all the sacrifices and all the
uh nuclear expenditures and all of that
had all been worth it and that argument
actually still goes on many people
say well if it wasn't for the star wars
initiative that would never have
happened
i've actually never found that a
persuasive argument myself i think that
a huge credit still has to go to mikhail
gorbachev really oh yeah because i mean
he he openly told the governments of
east germany and hungary and poland and
czechoslovakia we're not coming to your
aid
if you can't keep the support of your
people who can keep it if you can't if
you don't have it
we can't make up the difference and he
he took the risk he and his then foreign
minister mr shepherd nancy
of letting it run um still hated by the
old line stannis for this reason and i
don't think credited enough by the
people who say that
the berlin wall fell down because ronald
reagan made a fighting speech
not to take the credit away from that
speech but i think that the dissidence
of eastern europe and the um
moral fiber of mikhail sagarovich
gorbachev have a lot to do with it
thought so at the time things so still
what was your opinion of ronald reagan
in 1989
very low i have to say has it changed
yeah a bit
i mean he is a figure in history in a
different way from the one i would have
awarded him who am i to be awarding
these things but
then you know i i couldn't forget that
he had said things
like um don't start me but you know
the south african government has stood
beside us in every war we've ever fought
it was just that was his comment on a
part of it but in fact the south african
ruling party the national party had been
on the other side in the second world
war
um but if you remember intercontinental
ballistic missiles once launched could
be recalled
remember that um that the russian
language had no word for freedom he said
that the word is forbidden by by the way
i don't speak russian very well
he often gave me the impression of
knowing neither knowing nor caring
anything about the subject at all and
being a very dangerous guy
he also used to like to ruminate in
public about the end of days and the end
times prophecies of the bible with
other wingnuts which i thought was
exactly what you don't want
during a potential nuclear standoff but
he did he did actually have one thing
right which i actually always had in
common with him
um that the belief that it couldn't last
the service system couldn't last it was
doomed it was it was over no one
believed in it anymore
uh it was a matter of time and on that
point
okay has the role of the us and world
affairs change from 1989 to 2005
self-evidently yes i mean in how many
ways would you like us to do it
um
you want to narrow the question a bit
you take it wherever you want
um i'll give you one example actually
because
a very 89 was a big year for me apart
from the fact that it was the year i
became 40.
uh on valentine's day 89
the ayatollah khomeini issued a fatwa
first time we heard the word fatwa i
think or most people did
saying that he would offer money in his
own name
for the subordinate murder of a novelist
uh living in england who happens to be a
friend of mine was a friend of mine
salman rushdie i thought that was an
unprecedented challenge not just to what
we might call first amendment values but
you know to civilization really and
what impressed me then and depressed me
too was how many people said no no
the problem is not the ayatollah the
problem is rusty rushed you asked for
this he brought it on himself by writing
a novel
critical of islamic tradition
or of the literal interpretation of the
quran and
among the people who said this was then
president bush
who wasn't interested particularly in
in this you said no american interest is
involved in this question
uh mr rushdie isn't you know leftist
author we don't care about him marlon
fitzwater i remember said i
know marvin fitzwater said the same
thing
i remember thinking this is
extraordinary there's a frontal
challenge coming at us from islamic
extremism and the
republican government doesn't seem to
give a damn and in fact mr bush is
fairly fresh from his
iran-contra racketeering negotiations
and may still
have a sneaking sympathy for the people
he was doing business with in hostage
trading and arms trading and undermining
the constitution and
in order to punish nicaragua
so i'm not claiming uh the mantle of
prophecy here
or prescience but i do remember
distinctly thinking this is new and
we'll be hearing more about it and there
is
coming a confrontation with
fundamentalist islam and i don't think i
was wrong about that
our guest is christopher hitchens who
has sat at this table
38 times since november 7th 1983 almost
as much as carl lubstorff and susan page
who are the
two of the top winners 44 times and 40
times for them
we're talking about the year 1989 and
the role of the u.s
in the world in in a more general sense
you can see once again it's five in the
morning here on the east coast and look
at those phone lines
every single one of them lit up so let's
get right to them
a 10-year watcher from springfield
illinois you're on with christopher
hitchens
good morning christopher good morning as
you know yesterday october the 7th
was c-span's 25th call-in anniversary
but it was also the fourth anniversary
of the afghanistan war
fair enough okay i guess you must be
right now
yeah another point i want to make it was
also the feast day
of our lady a victory in the battle of
apontol
which was on october the 7th 1571.
so where are we going caller for me
where are we going with this
well i just want to connect that to 911.
because sovieski
the king of poland defeated the turks
at vienna on september the 12th 1683
and 9 11 was the eve of that battle so i
just thought there might be a connection
between
the battle of aponto and the battle of
vienna
well i'm not usually one to enthuse
about
um our lady of any kind uh whether it's
lord
or um calcutta but i think i'm the first
person to point out in print
that the the defeat of the ottoman
empire of the gates of vienna did take
place depending on which calendar not
which county is which time zone you
imagine yourself to be in
on i think actually september the 10th
11th
of 1683 uh and i pointed that out
not long after 9 11. i i can't believe
that that date isn't significant
for the al-qaeda forces because after
all it is the mission of bin laden
also he says so he boasts to restore
the lost caliphate based in istanbul
constantinople
i think that's quite likely to be
relevant in their minds though they've
never
made a point of it in any communique as
for le panto
i think that may be coincidence a
certain coincidence as far as the war in
afghanistan goes
um but though i'm not by any means a
believing catholic i do think one of the
finest
battle poems ever written it was by gk
chesterton
about le panto and i can even quote the
opening staves if anyone challenges me
on that
white white clouds falling in the courts
of the sun and the sultan of byzantium
is smiling as they run and it goes on to
build up this fantastic naval
naval battle where the forces of
christendom vanquish the turks
magnificent truly forced by chesterton
when it comes to the us role in the
world
where does the iraqi war fit into that
iraq happens to be the front line
of the battle between civilization and
barbarism if you want me to be as
simplistic as i can be
it's the country chosen by the forces of
jihad
some time ago as their next frontline
state
they were planning this before they were
evicted from afghanistan they knew
what anyone could see which is that iraq
was moving from being a rogue state to a
failed state actually was already both
things it was imploding
mr zakawi and other nightmarish
characters already making their way
there
the regime itself had become a jihadist
regime was pumping out
propaganda not for secularism as some
idiots will tell you but
entirely for holy war the federation
saddam was becoming one of the strongest
paramilitary forces in the state
there are people who say they even said
yesterday after the president's speech
this wouldn't be true if we hadn't
invaded it
actually the contrary is true that's the
way it was going we should have been
taking care of iraq a lot
sooner than we did um
and the line's now been drawn in a way
that i don't think can be altered
um we we are not going to i hope even
consider
surrendering a country in a society of
that importance to whom
to which and to whose members we've made
so many promises in the past
with whom we've incurred so many
responsibilities we're not going to say
we walk away from this and abandon them
to them
the tender mercies of jihadism is out of
the it's out of the question
to do that next call for christopher
hitchens comes from chicago
a 10-year watcher good morning
hello go ahead chicago uh yes um
hello yes you're on the air go ahead um
well
christopher i um i
uh i've also been reading
you for 10 years in the nation and
i very much enjoyed your column there
and i know people have asked you
um over and over again you know um
what happened um what the change brought
about and maybe you could address that
more generally but i wanted to ask you
well since this is about 1989 in 1989 as
you know
um the u.s was still actively sponsoring
um militant islam i.e the mujahideen
and um i noticed these days you're
focusing on the problem of islamic
fundamentalism and
rightly so obviously though the
rise of islamic fundamentalism or
militant islam didn't happen in a vacuum
didn't u.s imperialism kind of put that
on steroids and secondly why aren't you
focusing as much on the global
phenomenon of religious fundamentalism
with christian fundamentalism that's
happening in the united states it's
quite nasty i feel like thank you caller
well um if we just keep it 289
as in point of fact you're mistaken
because the red army was out of
afghanistan
by then though you are right in saying
that the united states
and china and egypt and many other
countries
help the afghan resistance to the red
army occupation but i don't see that
there was any choice but
to do that and if you ask yourself what
the roots of islamic fundamentalism are
why are people uh some of whom took part
in that struggle why do they decide that
their main enemies that
is the country that actually helped them
against the soviet union there must be
something irrational here or something
about their own position that they
haven't declared
and i think you you would if you
inquired find out very easily what it
was mr bin laden has
always said that the struggle to evict
communism from afghanistan was a tough
struggle long
hard one in which many of his comrades
died um
there would come a later struggle with
the united states the american empire
which he thought would be easy because
the united states would be a pushover
didn't have the ability or willingness
to fight
was run by jews and women and
homosexuals and was corrupt and
hedonistic
a lot depends on proving him wrong i
would say
in the struggle to do that i think
obviously one needs a critique of
religion
yes and um
since you were kind enough to say been
reading my stuff i'm sorry if you've
missed
what i've written about
jewish fundamentalism for example in the
west bank and gaza
the millennial settlers have had a
long long engagement with them and with
their supporters and
their attempt to bring on the messiah in
this way is wicked and deserves to be
defeated and
not one american dollar should go to
subsidizing it and um
i've also attacked various other
religious crackpots and fanatics like
mother teresa so-called
the saints the alleged saint of calcutta
who
fraud and democrat and fanatic and of
course um
if you want to move it even nearer home
i mean i think that the people who
say they believe in what they call
intelligent design have scored exactly
only one victory and it's the only one
they'll ever get which is to get us all
to call it intelligent but it's not
by the way i think we should stop
referring to it is that i think we
should call it id
or something of the sort and put it
always in inverted commas but it's like
saudi arabia once you call it after its
royal family the royal family are
praised by everyone who mentions the
name we should stop doing that and we
should stop saying intelligent design
for what is
scientific and moral and political fraud
when did you leave that i spent most of
my life fighting against religion in all
its forms
sorry about that when did you leave the
nation i resigned from the nation not
long after
the 11th of september of 2001 and
a little bit before the intervention in
iraq because i was fed up with the um
the masochistic tone that the magazine
took about
the confrontation with jihadism and its
totalitarian allies it was basically
saying well this must
have something to do with american
foreign policy must be a revenge for
something we did wrong
i thought no i'm not listening to a bar
of that song
don't you tell me that a movement that
wants to stone amina lawal
the nigerian woman who was
provably adulterous because she was
holding a baby in her arms without a
husband
is doing that because they want to help
the palestinians don't make me laugh
don't take me for a fool i know that's
not true do you think they enslave
afghanistan in order to emancipate the
gaza strip do you think they
blow up shia mosques in iraq
uh because they care about
oppressed people and they're murdering
their
their co-religionists or versions of the
coalition's every day
if you want to think what they might
want to do for us or to us just see what
they do to other muslims
and i couldn't get this simple point
across to most of my colleagues of the
nation so i
quit um and felt instantly much better
um do you ever uh feel any pressure from
vanity fair
when you write about iraq no i can
safely say i don't i mean the editor
takes a very forward position of his own
but to his credit if he decides to do
that in his own column his editorial
letter in the magazine he doesn't
inflict it on others who write for it he
he awards himself the space which he
could easily in which he could easily
discuss other things
um and um he and i have debated it a
couple of times on television
no there would be no no hint of that but
by the way i shouldn't
even imply that there was any such hint
of the nation either they never tried to
change anything i wrote but there came a
point when i thought would
that not just the editor is in grade and
cardi's case but the magazine itself had
become a sort of echo chamber as i
put it for people who thought that john
ashcroft was more dangerous than osama
bin laden and as i say i'm
i'm totally sick of that that mentality
that massacres and that falsification of
the
of the reality you can see it disproved
every day these people
are murdering muslims in indonesia
in iraq and nigeria they're not the
product of
poverty and unemployment they are the
cause of poverty and misery and
unemployment we
have to get this right or we will get
everything else wrong
and we'll be committing cultural and
political suicide and
i'm not willing to stand by and see that
happen a
25-year viewer from los angeles thanks
for holding and you're on the air with
christopher hitchens
thanks mr i'm mr thank you for getting
to the truth of the letter that i've
sent on cindy sheen's behalf to abc's
nightline i don't agree with your
position on the war but i very
much appreciate you getting out the
truth and the sidebar of your piece for
slate.com on august
um 18th i believe anyway you and i have
been in touch
um via email yes your justice quest
don't you yeah and you know that i
disagree with your position
i do know that yeah about religion there
are a lot of issues you and i agree on
very much bottom line is mr richards you
know that we were attacked on
back at the on in 1993 at the world
trade center
and tragically on 911 because of us
support for israel
robert pappy's you know what i'm gonna
leave him because
he called in he got in between eight and
nine this evening he's a repeat caller
he
breaks the rules he breaks the 30-day
rule he gets him yeah
and no matter we could be talking about
okay economic policy
it would be the same i know that you
hear from him he's a very assiduous
emailer to me and he's actually of the
ones i get is one of the brighter ones
and he did
having promoted miss sheen who's i'm
sure known to all your
audience um he did point out to me
that she had said agreeing with him in
point of fact that
her son had been killed by george bush
not by the people who actually killed
him and had been killed in a jewish war
for israel
and when i challenged ms sheen and said
is that what you're using
the memory of your son to promote she
denied ever having said it which she had
and blamed this gentleman for inserting
it into her email in other words the
next thing you're going to hear from ms
sheeran is she has
messages from outer space in the
fillings of her teeth she's a flake and
a moral coward because she wouldn't
stand by
what she had actually said and he was
brave enough to point this out to his
co-thinkers so i'm grateful to him for
that but
anyone who believes that um we were
attacked
on 911 because of american support for
israel is fooling themselves and
attempting to fool others the
i repeat the question what is the what
is the connection between the murder of
17 indonesians last week
in bali or the stoning of a nigerian
woman who's committed adultery or the
banning of polio vaccine by the imams of
northern nigeria because they think it's
a u.n u.s plot
or any of these things and and the
emancipation of the palestinians from
occupation there's no connection
at all mr bin laden does not believe in
a palestinian state
that's why he has almost no palestinian
supporters he believes that palestine
should eventually become part of a
greater caliphate
that would be run by people like him
he's not anti-imperialist
he's for the restoration of a lost and
barbarous empire
and i i have to suspect not in the case
of this caller i must say but in
the case of people who can't stay off
israel that there's something suspect
about their obsession with the jewish
question
i'll put it no higher uh what is the
flag on your lapel
it's the flag of kurdistan if you could
sit back i think the camera is going to
go in take a peek
this is the flag of the kurdish people
whose emancipation especially in the
three northern provinces of iraq
has been the most spectacular success of
the regime change policy
for those who don't know about this at
all the if i can just say word on their
behalf
the kurds are the largest stateless
minority in the middle east in fact
they're the largest stateless people in
the world we
there's no firm estimate of their
population it's probably between 26 and
30 million
living in turkey iran iraq and syria
roughly where that border converges
uncomfortable place to live
geopolitically but they've been there
for a very long time
and have been dispossessed and
as you know not long ago was subjected
to an attempted genocide by saddam
hussein involving the use of
weapons of mass destruction and are
beginning to find their feet as a
as a minority and to express themselves
and achieve a version of self-government
which i think is
a very worthwhile cause and one that
should be better known and should have
more support
in the west so i'm very proud to wear
their flag and be their friend
in 1989 the year that the berlin wall
came down the population of the world
was about 5.2 billion
u.s population 247 million currently
about 300 million
median income up to almost 29 000
unemployment rate 5.3 u.s
debt 2.9 trillion federal budget 1.1
trillion were well over 2.2 trillion
today
the deficit at that point was 153
billion
uh economic growth 3.5
c-span was available in about half
about 48.6 million homes today it's
available in about 90 million homes
next call for christopher hitchens
seattle washington
20 years of watching c-span good morning
hello go ahead seattle i i'm uh
i'm really wondering how this whole uh
religious uh uh fight
that uh uh gut
you know with weapons of mass
destruction
and i mean it was saudi arabians that uh
were all the bombers and
and for somehow along the line
we're ending up to turn this as some
kind of a religious
fight we're going to show them a better
way to live
and i don't understand it i don't
understand it at all all right thank you
caller it doesn't sound as if he
does i have to say um i think i'd rather
take that as a comment
i was trying to think while he was
talking was i making 29 000 in 1999
were you i'm sure i was
flushing new york well speaking of
what's your what's your u.s citizenship
status well i plan to become a citizen
um after 2001 as a
gesture really i suppose i mean i have a
platinum green card in other words it's
one of those ones that doesn't run out
and i have three american children and
pay american taxes on that money and all
this but i thought no i should really i
was cheating on my dues if i didn't
apply the citizenship but the paperwork
has gone into the labyrinth of homeland
security and i don't know whether i'll
ever hear from it again
and you apply it after 2001 and you
still yeah i should have it's still out
there
don't what it's like for people who are
trying for the first time who aren't
english haven't been here for a long
time
um and so forth i i can't imagine
but because i have you know a certain
number of advantages and
i i can't even i can't get i can't get
them to reply except they keep promising
you know you'll hear in 90 days and that
was
many many 90-day periods ago and they
cashed the check then
did you have to hire look if they didn't
want me i didn't insist but i felt that
i ought to be i ought to make
i would i would make the right
move i want to do the right thing have
you hired a lawyer to help you are you
doing it
you've does it make it easier to hire
the lawyer more so
that you have a lawyer who who because
of my book her mother teresa said she'd
do it for free as a matter of fact but
um so i didn't hire her but uh
but and she's very good it's what she
does but no the backlog is so terrible
and the bureaucracy is anyone who's had
any homeland security dealings knows is
insane and um not in this case but in
most other cases probably lethal
lethally
stupid and bureaucratic christopher
hitchens book on mother teresa is called
the missionary position his most recent
book is
thomas jefferson author of america that
came out in may
yes next call for him is flushing new
york
ten year watcher hi hi congratulations
c-span
thanks and uh thanks for watching uh
hello can you hear me go ahead okay i i
i you were talking before mr hutchins
you were talking before about
um you know uh ronald reagan and the uh
you know the fall of the berlin wall i
was to understand that
we in this country were in very bad
shape in the 80s i mean i can remember
was after the
vietnam war we had watergate we had
everything everything was going bad
the the soviet union was uh it looks
like a powerhouse
i think the only one that believed that
it wasn't or a few people believed that
it wasn't
was ronald reagan and i think he refused
to deal with the russians
he refused to deal with them uh until
they enlisted some of you know
what treated the people gave the people
more freedom i think once that happened
the people became you know the the
people uh
once they got their freedom they didn't
want to go back to uh
to a dictatorship and i think george
bush the father
i think he's the one that wanted to he
didn't believe that
we could uh he he was better off with
the
the the situation the way it was he
didn't you know he didn't know about a
new democracy
but what i'm saying is the sun now goes
over to iraq
and and i think it was a gutsy move and
i think we needed to bring democracy
over there somehow we had it started
simply because
democratic nation you know nations don't
fight with one another and it's a way to
to deal with the terrorists
i don't know any other way but the
people in this country are screaming
against it
and i just don't understand but nobody
has another plan
another thought on the subject and i i
did read a book with natan
i think it's shransky's yes a case for
democracy
and it made so much sense what he said
that people once they are liberated they
don't want to go back
it's like asking the blacks if they want
to go back to slavery
caller um thank you for your comments
can i ask why are you
calling a call-in show at 5 30 in the
morning you're just getting up have you
been watching all night woke up yeah hi
welcome and i uh do you turn on c-span
first thing in the morning
i do i do indeed that's the first and i
watch it every morning and
i think it's it just proves the case for
democracy
this is a place where every one of us
can call in
voice our opinion and not be carried off
to jail
thank you for calling and thank you for
watching christopher hitchens
well to take your points in order i
think you're right
that um ronald reagan was unusual even
in the republican world in his view
about the final
demise of communism and i'll give you
two instances that would
make your case in a way george bush who
you
contrasted with him had been head of the
cia for quite a long time
just prior to this and the central
intelligence agency continued to report
that the soviet economy was booming that
the soviet armed forces were going great
guns that the whole
russian system was in in tremendous
shape and of course as we
found out that was and some of us
suspected or knew or could at least
argue that was false it was a system was
completely corroded from within
especially in its eastern european
dependencies and it just took one shelf
to bring it down
you have to remember there was something
we haven't touched upon which is
in early 89 in my memory
of february march april i should have
this more closely
memorized but the the rising in
beijing of the students of
the university there in tiananmen square
and the unforgettable images of the
democratic statute
they put up and the stand they made
before the tanks came now if you notice
a lot of republicans and and you'd have
to include even ronald reagan in this
were
quite quiet about that because china
after all was an american ally at the
time and
in some ways still is against the soviet
union in fact um henry kissinger
came right out and said that if he if
he'd been the government of china he'd
have done the same thing
in that square and he said you you can't
expect them to put up with protest of
this kind so
real policy doesn't completely give way
uh to idealism in this
in this respect and after all uh for the
same reason
mr reagan and his government had
recognized insisted on recognizing the
khmer rouge
as the government of cambodia and seat
them as the representatives of cambodia
at the united nations when they were not
quite apart of the fact that they
shouldn't have been they actually were
not the legal government of cambodia
and i i stress this because i don't
think we've reached a point where we can
say we've
left real policy behind we still have to
make
a lot of the time or it is still
believed by some that we do have to make
compromises with
dictatorial and aggressive regimes as
lesser evils
and you notice if you put the word
lesser in front of evil people don't
complain they laugh when the president
says axis of evil they say evil
how simplistic can you get but if you
put lesser in front of it all liberals
think evil is a perfectly okay word
we have we have not finished hashing
this out i think but
the process was well begun in 1989
because it was a year really of
of human liberation on on a very very
large
and memorable scale and that's why i
loved every minute of that year even
though some of it went so badly
we're in hour 10 of our 25 hour marathon
this will go through 9 p.m on saturday
night
we appreciate you're all watching
cincinnati you're on the air go ahead
first time caller welcome thank you very
much
i was wondering if mr hitchens could uh
comment on
what he considers the morality of h.w
bush i think that he started some
policies continued by president reagan
and
my viewpoint is that george
h.w bush will go down in history as one
of the most corrupt presidents we've
ever
had why is that caller
i think he started i know he started
some policies in the dod
that um have been carried through until
today
and that it was he personally that
promoted some of these policies and
that um now the dod is stuck with
do you can you give us an example of one
of those um
not right now no i cannot i'm okay and
can i ask you have you uh are you just
getting up and watching or you've been
watching all night or
i was awakened at 4 00 a.m so that i
could possibly get
on c-spand and talk to mr hitchens
yes there you go thank you very much
well thank you for that thought look um
at the time i remember why i couldn't
stand the sight of uh
george herbert walker bush it was
because of the way he lied about his
role in the iran-contra
matter which i i thought then and think
now
was one of the most uh horrible
deliberated sabotages of constitutional
rule in this country that there ever was
and
just to remind you it involved people
working in the basement of the white
house
for a president who for whom they could
claim deniability but who was
their president as well as the
legitimate president to raise a private
budget
which the constitution quite flat out
forbids
without the knowledge of congress to
trade in hostages with the ayatollahs
in iraq and to use the profit of that to
finance a bunch of goons in nicaragua
you could not have a more flagrant
violation of the constitution and um the
president of the day
mr reagan was very lucky to escape
impeachment in my view
some of his aides had to go to jail and
many others had to be
convicted of lying to congress and the
vice president flat out lied about his
part in it
and i never forgave him for it and i
still can't look at his face without
remembering that um i'd have to say
that he did take the decision
um though he was partly responsible for
the original mistake that allowed it to
occur
and criminal policy that allowed it to
occur he did take the decision that
the regime of saddam hussein could not
be allowed to take over the state of
kuwait
remember people lazily say saddam
hussein invaded kuwait he did nothing of
the kind
he annexed kuwait and made it part of
iraq he abolished a member state of the
united nations and of the arab
and if he'd been able to get away with
it would have had the resources with
which to complete his nuclear program
and in retrospect i support president
bush on that much more than i did at the
time
so it's very rare that you have someone
who's completely
useless as a president i don't think
since i think bill clinton would
probably be the only one
who might as well never have been born
in 1989 was the same year we uh the u.s
went into panama wasn't it
it was 1889 as a partial trade-off
i remember it very well because it was
just before christmas
and just as the uh the last of the
communist dictatorships in eastern
europe the one that wasn't dependent so
much on moscow
romania chaucesko's
fiefdom i was there for the death and
overthrow of mr
and to my amazement um just before this
happened james baker
made a speech then secretary of state
saying to moscow to president gorbachev
we don't mind if russia intervenes in
romania now because it's such a horrific
dictatorship in this time it went you
know if you feel you have to you
you have american permission i've lived
to see an american secretary of state
saying we don't care if the red army
intervenes in an american and excuse me
in a european country but quite clearly
what that was was a sort of trade-off
for the fact that the united states had
had enough of mr noriega in panama
for one reason or another not all of
them creditable
and was going to go in and sort that out
unilaterally
um and in the sort of in the
extraordinary kaleidoscope of events
that christmas boxing day new year
all of that got overlooked but boy it
was fascinating to live through it
uh what was it like to be in romania
when the coaches didn't end up getting
hung
upside down kind of like a mussolini am
i right about that no but they were they
were
it i mean it was nearly that bad they
were shot
there's a video of them being next
actually they were kept inside
they were captured they were kept inside
a tank for a while as a jail cell
and they were dragged out and given a
very brief hearing in front of us a drum
head
tribunal and then put up against the
wall of machine gun
which meant that there was never a trial
and never a full inquest into how they'd
run romania and we could never be sure
who exactly was who was behind this coup
um a lot of people thought well if
anyone had it coming he and his old
ghastly wife eleno did but
i i and i've so thought that myself a
bit
uh and he killed an awful lot of people
in the rallying against him and his
black uniformed
super police were renowned for their
lethality but there was something sorted
and creepy about it
in fact because the rebellion began in
transylvania
the sort of hungarian-oriented bit of
remain everyone
compared it to a sort of vampire trial
and a driving of a stake through the
heart so that the dictator could never
come back
had that surreal character to it and the
place was freezing
and starving and terrified and you saw
people who'd
never known a minute of life without
permanently having to see charizard on
the screen
or hearing his ten hour speeches you
know they couldn't believe that
that this monster had actually died
it took them a long time to to accept it
a bit like
the iraqis when they heard about the
deaths of kusai has saying even when
they saw the bodies they didn't believe
it they thought this is fake
we have about 10 minutes left with our
guest over the years we've had well over
12 thousand individual
guests on the c-span call-in programs
and as we take this next call we're
gonna look at some of those
politicians who have been on the air
with us morenci michigan thanks for
holding your own with christopher
hitchens go ahead
hi christopher how are you a bit early
to say
i really enjoy listening to you and
watching whenever i
see you on which is why i'm up this
morning but thank you um
i was wondering what your thoughts would
are regarding
bush's invasion of iraq and and why he
hasn't framed his argument around
um the weapons of mass destruction
in in the sense that even if
his intelligence had said that
there may not be weapons of mass
destruction we don't know at the point
of
it seems to me by the end of 2002
having defied the u.n and hence the
world for i guess 17 different
resolutions
letting the inspectors in kicking them
out letting them in kicking them out i
think four or five times
yes it seems to me that if he had said
look i'm not sure if their weapons of
mass destruction but
at this point and i believe saddam
hussein should have led those inspectors
by the hand and said this
is where they were because we knew he
had them after the gulf war
he used them on the kurds killed
thousands of people he should have taken
those
inspectors by the hand and said this is
where they were
this is what we did to get rid of them
this is the documentation to prove it
and anything short of that in my opinion
regardless of whether we had proof that
they were there we at the time we knew
they were there at one point
uh i think if bush had framed his
argument and and with that in that
respect
i think he would have had a lot less
heed a lot less criticism
from people saying that he framed or you
know his basis for attacking was that
and yet it and then they weren't found
you know okay i understand perfectly
what what you're saying and actually
what you're saying is common sensical if
you're the leader of a democratic
country
that's just undergone a terrorist attack
and is expecting the possibility of a
worse one
and you're confronted with a dictator
who has praised this attack
and given shelter to some of the people
past and present who are interested in
that kind of thing
uh which we know that saddam was doing
and can be proved to anyone
uh and you are you gonna face your
voters and say well let's give him the
benefit of the doubt
let's uh let's let's grant saddam
hussein the presumption of innocence
this is also as you say the only
regional government has actually used
weapons of mass destruction not just
within its own borders but against iran
as well
it has a proven record of concealment a
special ministry to conceal
weapons and to deceive inspectors um who
by the way are not investigators they're
supposed to be just monitored
i think the only thing you could
possibly say is there is no more
presumption of innocence here
there's no more benefit of the doubt
we're going to say as
if and nothing else would be sane
or defensible but um in fact that is in
effect what the president and his
advisers
said and tony blair too and
we still haven't found the weapons that
iraq declared that it had before the war
so the question is not ha ha ha we
didn't find them but where are the
weapons there aren't claimed to have
that
but you're wrong in thinking that would
have made any difference to the
president's critics these are people who
would have been against a war with iraq
under any circumstances
at all and you can see the people who
run this movement now
and the sort of propaganda they come up
with they're the same people who said we
shouldn't invade afghanistan because it
would be another vietnam there was no
question
there of the al-qaeda connection was
there but they still said leave it alone
this mentality is incurable and though
i've been
strong critic of the way the president
has handled his public relations
in this in his argument i i do not
believe
that any any argument at all will win
over the people who are
either openly or secretly sympathetic to
the other side in this war people like
george galloway
people like cindy sheehan who basically
openly have said that they regard the
jihadists in iraq and afghanistan as a
resistance as a as an insurgent popular
movement
and who believe that as and say openly
as does michael moore and others
uh that bush is the terrorist problem
not bin laden well
people like that are not going to be
convinced by evidence
it was 22 years ago that uh christopher
hitchens first appeared
on our call-in programs there's what he
looked like
hammond indiana hello
hello go ahead hammond you're on the air
wow yes uh
chris uh i was wondering this
this so-called you know this taliban
mentality over there
now you know we it's very easy for us to
look at them as being wackos and
fanatics but don't you think that on
their side
they're doing the same thing about our
say fundamentalist christians when they
hear somebody like
franklin graham saying that new orleans
is uh
you know being a punishment from god and
stuff don't you think that they're using
the same kind of propaganda on
us as well you know from their point of
view
you know we're and we can't change how
do you change a person's ideology you
know
well i mean it does amaze me that people
like pat robinson and jerry falwell who
said that the world trade center was a
punishment for
i forget now what abortion or sodomy or
something of the sort are still in
business in any way that anyone quotes
them or
pays any attention or sense in any of
their hard-earned savings um
but but their position and their
mentality has always struck me as
ludicrous and hateful and ignorant and
superstitious
and uh having made myself plain on that
i still don't believe that
they are the same as those who
for example uh put bombs in mosques
um in iraq in order to create a strategy
of
misery no they're not they're not the
same as that but the religious mentality
the idea that faith is superior to
reason and that you can interpret god's
will
and you can you can claim as a human
mammal to know what it is
and tell other people what to do on that
basis and
claim that you you're not just created
but supervised and that you understand
the cosmos i mean the unbelievable
arrogance of that is of course always
dangerous and can always lead to
violence but
ah i mean i would still say steady on
it's not a matter of propaganda it's a
matter of action
of deed if you like last call i haven't
got over that picture of myself
last call for christopher hitchens
sacramento
you've been watching for three years
right yes
hi uh i uh
i'm a big fan of christopher i've read a
lot of his
um analysis i have two questions in
regards to iraq
the first question is what
do you think that if the democrats the
democratic candidate
john kerry had won in um 2004
what his response would have been to
iraq and what he might have done
um aside from what you know the
obviously the political posturing that
that's taking place
kind of extreme what he actually would
have done would have actually been the
real
possible consequences and and my second
question is
what do you think the the actual
consequences now of just
pulling out or not even just pulling out
if we
what do you think not committing
ourselves
in the long run um to backing the iraqis
up what the actual long-term effect of
that would be
for the us and the world in general
thank you very much
sure well very quickly because i think
we're getting the
the signs of wind wind up in a in a
small way i
half wish that john kerry would be
elected because he had promised several
times he said
the president doesn't have a victory
strategy for iraq but i do
i know how to win this war and i'll show
you how but i would have liked to see
him try and i'd also like to see his
party committed
to his election on that basis because
now they don't talk about victory
strategy anymore they may never have
been
what they mean really to talk about his
exit strategy in other words how to find
a way to capitulate
and i think that's disgraceful and on
principle
and i don't think i have to draw you a
picture of what iraq would look like
if the coalition withdrew before we've
guaranteed
to our friends and allies there who are
the majority of the population currently
going through a very arduous and very
interesting
process of trying to evolve a
constitutional form of federalism
after 35 years of divide and rule and
fascism and war
and the the incitement of sectarian and
confessional disagreements it's a
miraculous thing to see
we have no right to abandon them it
seems to me
either in their interests or in ours but
if you
if you want to see what it would look
like
if if capitulation was
brought about you only have to look at
mr zakawi's manifestos or
look up some of the videos that he's
so helpfully produced for you about how
he treats those who he's captured and
butchers them
live on camera or um how he's gone to
all the trouble
of calling his organization al-qaeda and
mesopotamia i mean he's pedantically
laid it out for you what he wants
i would have thought that should decide
it for people but i know that
i'm in a minority in thinking this but i
don't care
our guest for the last hour has been
christopher hitchens vanity fair
thank you so much for getting up at oh
dark whatever and
get out of this data but thank you for
having me you're taking bets on that
it's no worse than coming in at seven or
eight i promise you
very nicely to us and it's almost 6 a.m
out here in the east for the next three
hours rob
harliston is going to be out here at the
table as the host we've got some great
segments coming up
and uh you'll hear about those in just a
minute for the last four hours the
overnight shift has included greg
sizowitz as our director andrew nason
has been the producer
danny boone has been on camera chuck
george has been doing the audio board
john kane has been the floor director in
here in the studio with us and
rick stoddard has been answering the
phones if you had a chance to get in
the new crew is now taking over christy
slafka is sitting in the
producer's chair and jen imdorf has
moved into the
phone answer position enjoy the rest of
our marathon which goes through
9 pm eastern time on saturday
it's time once again for you to meet one
of the 25 c-span viewers
who have entered and won in c-span's
25th anniversary of the call-in
essay contest on the telephone with us
from lahui hawaii it's christina carlson
she watches c-span on oceana cable hello
miss carlson
hello susan well tell me about lahui it
sounds lovely
oh it is beautiful it says it's a small
lounge it's the capital of kauai it's uh
it's not very large and um well it's
just beautiful
how long have you lived there i've lived
on the huli for
i've lived here for about seven years
now in hawaii for about 20 years
and when you were on the mainland where
was home seattle washington
and what took you to hawaii well i came
here on vacation once and decided this
is where i wanted to live so i
came back here and did some graduate
work at the university of hawaii in
order to
qualify as a teacher and some other
positions
and that's how i got here good for you a
lot of hawaii visitors always wish they
could and there you did it
yes how long have you been watching
c-span oh about 20 years now
well you tell us more about your c-span
watching in your essay so how about if
we have you read that and then we'll
come back and talk some more
all right why i watch
and participate viewer call-ins on
c-span
i watch and participate in viewer
call-ins on c-span
because i can't help it i've been an
unabashed c-span
junkie for nearly 20 years and i'm all
the richer for it
there is no other tv programming as
interesting and informative
it is a national treasure of free speech
with class
c-span viewer call-in programs provide a
smorgasbord
of current and reliable information not
otherwise available
to me i live and teach middle school
math and social studies
on kauai where tourists pay dearly to
get away from it all
and this is about as far as one can get
from
serious intellectual discourse
c-span viewer call-ins provide committed
lifelong learners
with virtual graduate level seminars in
subjects
ranging from international affairs
economics
political science public health
government policies
world religions literature science and
technology
these courses present vignettes
in 21st century world history and
culture
as it unfolds and without editing
c-span's guests are unscripted speaking
solely from their personal knowledge
experience and convictions
they respond to callers comments and
questions
directly and often candidly while
looking us right in the eye
the callers who are sometimes experts on
the topics being discussed
and often not provide alternative points
of view
on important issues plus i can weigh in
at any time if i persevere most of all
i appreciate each of c-span's wonderful
unflappable hosts
who facilitate lively dialogue between
callers and guests in a non-partisan
unbiased
and consistently gracious manner please
don't ever cut me off well christina
carlson
if there's a five-hour time difference
isn't there between washington
and hawaii uh yes uh during daylight
savings
time it's uh six hours and so it is
either one
or two a.m in the morning when
washington journal starts do you
actually watch it live
yes i do how do you how and why do you
do that
well uh susan you have been spent time
here you know we roll up our sidewalks
around here around uh when the sun goes
down
so since there's nothing good on tv
except silly sitcoms and things in the
evening i just go to bed at
seven o'clock and now my day starts at
one and i'm
it's my best time for me to study i do
all kinds of online
classes because i do graduate work
online just
because i love to best time in the world
for me to do
enjoy c-span and do my homework well
there's
there's a whole community of night owls
out there who are probably identifying
with you right now
well i wish i could we i wish we had a
focus group on kauai with c-span viewers
i've never heard anybody else call in
from kauai
and i i watch every day just about so
i i think i might be the only one here
this may unearth another one or two you
never know well that would be great
because i'm in the phone book so they
can find me
now what inspires you to pick up the
phone and call in
what kind of guest oh well i am very
interested in education of course and
especially when you have anyone on
that's talking about special education
students uh the the kind of students i
work with
um and then i also was very interested
in the during the election
with some of the um some of the things
that the candidates had to say during
well every time you have an election
i usually have some opinion about that
so uh but i'm really mostly content to
listen
i i find that most of your guests
ask the question just about the time i
think about it somebody will call in and
ask um
or you or one of the guests one of the
hosts will ask what i'm
interested in knowing about so it's um
i don't feel like i have to call in too
many times christina carlson a night owl
watching c-span on
oceania cable in lahui hawaii where it
starts as early as one o'clock in the
morning we appreciate all that watching
and thanks for participating in our
essay contest
oh you're welcome and thank you so much
for considering my essay
you can read christina carlson's winning
essay on c-span's website c-span.org
look for the 25-year viewer colin icon
coming up on our live 25-hour call-in
marathon a look at congressional
scandals with public television's kwame
holman
at 7 eastern joan biskupic of usa today
will join us to talk about the us
supreme court
and then former clinton chief of staff
john podesta on the bill clinton years
he'll be followed by a reason magazine
editor-in-chief nick gillespie
on the role of the media covering
washington
the entire 25-hour schedule is on our
website
cspan.org also learn how call-in
programs evolved on radio and tv
and more about c-span's 25 years of
call-in programs
cspan.org click on 25 years of viewer
call-ins